Il y a des villes qu’on identifie à coup
sûr, un coup d’œil rapide sur un bâtiment
au style architectural bien prononcé et ont
peut facilement dire
Paris
Londres
Bruxelles
Prague
Alors c’est vrai pour certaines villes
mais évidemment pas pour toutes car les images
que jviens de vous montrer elles proviennent
d’une seule et même ville à savoir Lille.
Lille où je me suis rendue il ya quelques
temps pour vous réaliser cette vidéo sur
son architecture.
Je ne sais pas si l’architecture
ça vous parle ?
Peut-être pas mais étudier
l’architecture, c’est en réalité, un
excellent moyen de comprendre l’histoire
d’une ville, ses rapports sociaux et ses
influences artistiques.
La première impression
que j’ai eu de la ville en arrivant ça
a été :
«C’est quoi ce bordel ? »
de la brique, de la pierre, du néoclassique,
du flamand, de l’archi moderne, contemporaine,
de l’art déco…. Bref, un bon gros mélange
de styles que j’ai essayé de détricoter.
Il n’échappera à personne que Lille est
une ville frontière ce qui l’expose davantage
aux influences des pays voisins, en l’occurrence
l’Angleterre, la Belgique, les Pays-Bas…
Du fait de sa position géographique, Lille
a également une fonction militaire importante,
ses frontières furent constamment menacées
: sa forteresse et sa citadelle construites
par Vauban dans la seconde moitié du XVIIe
siècle en témoignent.
Lille a la réputation d’une ville industrielle notamment
dans
la production et le commerce du textile depuis
la fin du Moyen Âge.
Mais c’est réellement
au 19eme, que l’industrie textile et métallurgique
va connaître un essor économique considérable
qui va se refléter nettement dans l’architecture
des habitations et des bâtiments publics.
On pourrait croire que « ville industrielle » signifie « ville ouvrière »
certes,
pour des raisons évidentes de main d’œuvre.
Mais « ville industrielle » ça veut avant
tout dire ville
d’industriels
patrons, ingénieurs, grands bourgeois.
Lille est un lieu où cohabitent
des grands patrons et des ouvriers, d’un
côté une classe dirigeante et aisée, de
l’autre une classe populaire et défavorisée.
on pourrait s’arrêter là, en ayant dit l’essentiel,
mais reprenons depuis le début.
Lors de la première révolution industrielle
il y a pénurie de logements ouvriers.
Des habitations sont donc élevées à la hâte
avec de mauvais matériaux, empêchant la
construction sur plusieurs étages
c’est
d’ailleurs l’une des premières choses
qui m’ait frappée dans cette ville : une
ville sans hauteur avec 2/3 étages maximum.
La courée devient l’habitat industriel
typique de Lille et de son agglomération.
Elle est composée d’une ou deux rangées
de maisons au cœur d’un îlot d’habitations,
cernant une cour.
Cette extension anarchique
et très rapide de petits quartiers favorisera
chez les familles ouvrières l’insalubrité
et la pauvreté.
Progressivement la bourgeoisie va redessiner
la ville grâce à la fortune acquise par
les activités textiles.
La priorité est
d’agrandir
c’est-à-dire au-delà des
remparts hérités de Vauban et d’assainir
la ville en régularisant les canaux pour
limiter les inondations.
Les grands projets
d’aménagements du paysage urbain commenceront
dès 1851 :
on construit des places, des ronds
points des portes triomphales.
Banquiers, industriels, propriétaires ou simples rentiers
achètent des parcelles le long de ces nouveaux
axes pour y bâtir des hôtels particuliers
et des maisons.
Lille est alors une ville façonnée par la bourgeoisie
et le restera
car le but est de spécialiser les quartiers
et non d’améliorer le logement ouvrier.
Ces réaménagements prennent pour modèle
des villes comme Londres et Paris.
On suit
les grands chantiers parisiens initiés par le baron Haussmann.
Les boulevards deviennent
les espaces de la bourgeoisie lilloise.
La mode est à l’éclectisme
ce qu’on voit
bien dans les différents styles de façades de la ville.
Du néoclassique à l’Art Nouveau
d’abord, puis à l’Art Déco jusque dans
les années 1930.
La brique, la pierre, parfois l’alliance
des deux, c’est un peu l’image que l’on
se fait des villes du Nord de la France et de l’Europe.
Pourtant en me documentant,
il s’avère que c’est un autre matériau
qui est à l’honneur à Lille bien que dissimulé,
j’ai nommé : le béton armé !
Malgré les bombardements de la première Guerre Mondiale,
Lille a conservé son centre historique intact
la place Rihour, la Grand’Place et celle
du Théâtre ont échappé aux bombes.
Pour les bâtiments et rues touchés, la politique
adoptée a été la suivante :
reconstruire à l’identique mais en intégrant de nouveaux matériaux
plus résistants et incombustibles
et pour cela le matériau parfait c’est
le béton armé !
En réalité, on a du mal
à croire que, derrière ces façades classiques
de pierre ou de brique, se cache une structure en béton armé
Côté déco, on respecte scrupuleusement
les styles historiques anciens et régionaux
quitte parfois à en faire des caisses.
Cette campagne architecturale de l’illusion est
une défense face aux nouveaux partis pris
modernes imposés par des architectes de renom
Le Corbusier, Mallet-Stevens
qui prônent l’architecture fonctionnelle, les lignes
épurées.
L’avant-garde et le régionalisme
vont s’installer dans la ville et venir
accentuer toujours plus les contrastes visuels.
Un exemple de l’architecture régionaliste
c’est typiquement la nouvelle Bourse.
Louis-Marie Cordonnier s’inspire pour ce bâtiment
du maniérisme flamand,
mais utilise de nouvelles techniques comme celle du béton armé.
Anecdote
au passage : durant sa restauration de 1987
à 1997 on a tenu à garder toutes les pierres
d’origines même celles qui n’étaient
plus saines pour préserver au maximum son
style et la polychromie d’origine.
On peut aussi évoquer l’hôtel de ville
connu pour son beffroi de 110 mètres de haut
qui est à l’époque la tour de béton armé la
plus haute du monde
c’est véritablement un triomphe technique et une vitrine pour
les entreprises qui ont œuvré à sa réalisation.
Pour l’avant-garde et l’architecture moderne,
ce sont essentiellement
des étudiants issus des classes aisées qui vont s’y intéresser
en particulier lorsque l’architecte Mallet-Stevens
prend la direction de l’école des Beaux
arts en 1925.
Robert Mallet-Stevens
se fait connaître dans les années 30 par la construction
de la villa Cavrois,
du nom du propriétaire, un riche industriel,
qu’il construit à Croix.
Cette villa est une œuvre d’art total
que je vous conseille d’aller visiter.
L’élément le plus frappant
c’est qu’elle a pour unité de base la brique
Vous souvenez de vos constructions LEGO ?
Et bien là c’est le même principe :
à aucun endroit la brique
n’est coupée pour s’adaptée aux dimensions,
on la garde intacte et on la met en valeur !
La brique est un outil de langage
Signe de richesse et de réussite pour certains
ou signe de pauvreté pour d’autres.
Elle est dans les vieux quartiers de Lille le plus
souvent cachée sous des couches de peintures
et de crépis pour donner l’illusion d’un
parement plus classique et aussi pour briser
la monotonie des habitations.
À quoi ressemble Lille aujourd’hui ?
Prenonsun peu de hauteur pour dire
qu’il y a comme des villes dans la ville,
plusieurs mondes qui se côtoient :
un nouveau quartier d’affaire qui se veut
le signe d’une métropole européenne active et créative
et puis les vestiges d’une ville désindustrialisée,
précarisée et bien moins visible.
Le contraste dont je vous parle depuis le
début de la vidéo est bien là, encore aujourd’hui.
Il m’a sauté aux yeux lorsque j’ai tourné
ces images et je pense qu’il en serait autant
pour n’importe quel voyageur arrivant à
Lille.
Vous sortez de la gare et le récent
complexe Euralille se dresse au dessus de
vous
et ces grandes tours de verre, construites
par des grands architectes surplombent la
ville.
Deux mots au sujets du projet Euralille
c’est un ensemble isolé,
qui n’a jamais
été intégré à la ville
c’était d’ailleurs la volonté de son concepteur.
Ce « onzième
quartier lillois » est par essence une anti-ville
qui a ses codes propres, ceux des nouveaux
quartiers d’affaire qu’on retrouve dans
la plupart des grandes villes européennes.
On peut remarquer que comme toutes les autres
métropoles françaises,
la ville de Lille est confrontée à un processus de gentrification.
La gentrification c’est l’embourgeoisement
de la ville,
l’appropriation par des couches
aisées de quartiers populaires.
des quartiers comme le vieux Lille, autrefois insalubre
est devenu aujourd’hui le plus cher de toute
la ville.
Autre quartier concerné celui-ci
de Wazemmes, au sud ouest de la ville où
l’habitat ancien a été réhabilité dans
les années 80 et
est aujourd’hui divisé de part et d’autre d’un marché cosmopolite
des étudiants et artistes d’un côté,
des classes populaires de l’autre.
La préservation de la richesse architecturale
de Lille,
de ses diverses influences à travers les âges
en a fait une ville très agréable
à vivre
ville aérée, contrastée.
Mais le défi actuel est sans doute,
au-delà de la mise en valeur de ce patrimoine
de conserver la mixité sociale
qui lui a permis d’exister.